hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become are you ready for this upper
body cardio circuit this workout it's
going to get your arms and you showed us
on fire and we want to be toning up
those bingo wings okay so you will be
throwing lots of punches and getting
down onto the floor right let's get
straight into the workout okay so the
first workout will be punches for those
of you who have done my kickboxing
workout video you will love this move so
what I want to do is stand with your
left leg forward right leg back Square
your hips looking forward keep your arms
close to your body okay keeping them
always close to your face because you
want to be guarding your face and throw
me left punch twist your body right
punch and twist okay so you're punching
straight into me let's go punch left and
right okay so remember to rotate your
hips at the same time remember the power
should come from the hips as you throw
the punches straight okay
so do not punch through the laughs or to
the right this is wrong straight punches
and pull it back in keep your arms
always close to your face same magic if
someone wants to punch you you have your
hands guarding your face okay so left
and right twist a hit rotate your hips
and throw me strong punches keep your
shoulders nice and light okay so imagine
that you're punching someone now throw
me few more strong punches straight
ahead speed it up and rest it out again
in your fighting stance left leg forward
right leg back both arms up this time we
want to throw some hooks so it's to the
side and to the side okay again remember
the rotation can turn your hips so hook
to the side hook whichever armor that is
not moving always keep it close to your
face alright so the power once more
from your hips okay that's where you
will gain more momentum and more
strength good so hook hook hook
okay do not drop your hands okay keep it
high up hook and punch someone on the
side of their cheek hook and hook good
keep going let's speed it up hook hook
nice and Shawn tight hooks small tight
hooks work your arms lift up your
triceps pull your elbows keep hooking
one last one and rest it out whoa so you
should feel your arms working right now
great let's get down onto the floor it
will be a plank walk with rotation so
start at the edge of your mat okay what
I wanted to do is that with the rotation
twist and I walk to the end of your mat
twist the opposite side
go back keeping a flat back walk and
rotate and twist and look up keep going
so walk right any edge twist and look up
okay minimal hip movement twist look up
and keep going strong nice plank whoa
burst of energy good
and now rotate one more walk okay let's
get right to the end
twist last one get back twist
and relax plank I've done we all know
this move and it is extremely effective
okay so what I want to do is stop in a
low plank position okay keeping your
body flat low plank position and ready
push yourself up and down and change
side up and down so alternating between
the left and right hand again with all
this workout minimal hip movement the
strength should come from your core as
well as your upper body down it up suck
your belly in down it up
and dump and up good left down right up
right down left up nice keep going you
are strong whoa remember pumps at
shoulder levels up and down last one
more down and rep it out okay great now
what I want to do is lie down onto the
mat okay what I'm going to do is give me
a front raise if you come up bring and
squeeze your legs all right
simple move but really effective up
squeeze your let muscles feel your back
down and up again squeeze down and
squeeze shoulders lifted engaging on
your lap do this and down hmm
nice
up as high as you can gaze gently just
slightly in front of you on to the bar
and down lift it up squeeze back down
squeeze imagine you're pooling and
you're squeezing something in between
your back
alright good now just get back up okay
your breathing should be hard the next
workout is I'm circles treat this work
as a slight easy cool down before moving
on to the next worker so I'm out okay
point a thumbs up I want you to give me
front arm circle okay rotate small
rotation keeping your arms up all the
time to keep the intensity so do not
drop it make a big circle
good and now let's go reverse big okay
and I'll keep it small and spit it up
okay so squeeze our shoulders together
point your elbows down thumbs point it
up and just keep circle rotating okay
keep going
ten more seconds treat this as a short
rest as well
alright good keep going circle few more
spit it up and relax it guess what more
push-ups okay I know most of us ladies
we hit push-up because it's not easy but
you know what I love to do it because
it's extremely effective and I want you
to be able to master push-ups beginners
if you need to start in your knees give
me a shirt a push-up and a me tap ok to
shoot a push-up tap on to the opposite
knee and show the push up tap as you
progress get up sugar push up tap tap
down again
okay point your butt up
and tap okay so get into a slide down
with duck and tap hike it but up and tap
good down tap and tap very good whoa do
those arms working tap and tap all right
relax okay
next white shirt a push-up will work
more on your chest and show this now we
want to go narrow grip so this will work
more on your triceps okay so again
beginners what you can do is start in
the knees
you'd be choice a push-up get up to
mountain climbers okay down tricep
pushup get up to mountain climbers all
right
as you progress get onto your knees up
elbows close your body get up to
mountain climbers good down push-up work
on your core and back down okay so your
elbows should be close to your body do
not point it out and this will target
more on your tricep tricep push-up is
much harder compared to show the
push-ups one more up squeeze it whoop I
can feel my choices let's burn those
bingo wings all right ha one set down
okay that was eight exercises in total
so just relax your shoulders rotate your
shoulders drink some water and we have
two more rounds to go
let's keep your heart rate up
all right keeping the hydrate up breathe
catch your breath
and we want to keep your heart rate
constantly up throughout the entire run
okay so give me food energy this is a
cardio circuit so we want to really push
through the 45 seconds and then breathe
in the 15 seconds and then push again
okay so you have 15 seconds left
all right let's get into a fighting
stance okay left leg forward right leg
back square your hips okay on top
remember relax your shoulders the power
energy should come from in hips let's go
right and left okay rotate your hips
twist and twist and twist good suck a
belly in move your hips okay guard your
face pull your aunts bus okay do not
just let it drop
pull it back work on your shoulders and
your triceps pull it back
suck a belly in keep your knees soft and
keep twisting alright good ten seconds
let's speed it up
let's go fast punches look straight
ahead fast punches come on go one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
hah rest very good no hooks okay still
in your fighting stance left and right
hooks again in your fighting stance you
always have to keep your left and right
hand close okay and rotate twist and
imagine you're hooking and punching
someone on the cheek let's go hook hook
okay guessing your form wrap do not drop
your hands down keeping it up small
movement but really powerful movement
coming from your hips hook and hook look
straight ahead
dunno look all over the place otherwise
someone else will be punching you let's
go hook and hook last ten seconds we
want to go for short
and really fast hooks okay ready
that's good ten seconds fast let's go
hook hook hook keep breathing
last one more and rest it out okay good
plank walk with a twist okay so I want
you to really work on your hands
your arms as well as your obliques okay
so start at the edge of your mat twist
rotate let's go walk right to the end
twist work in italics and to the end
twist
keeping your heart rate up breathe in
through your nose and out through your
mouth
keep going walk to the side and rotate
twist good good you have ten seconds
left
I'm sure you can go at least two more
walk to the left and to the right four
at eight one more to the end and rotate
all right are you ready for plank up
down okay so remember with plank up down
what I want to do is alternate between
left and right so get down push up with
your right down left down right down
left and down okay
find your speed find your rhythm and
keep the rhythm consistent
minimal hip movement okay its height in
a car suck your belly in minimal hip
movement stay strong stay with me up and
down ten seconds left
you got this strong arms turn of those
arms and you will be rocking sleeveless
tops okay let's do this let's get onto
your belly
front race with lat squeeze okay so
let's go up squeeze something in between
your back down again up squeeze up and
squeeze for one count release keep it up
and squeeze good if you want to you can
grab a light pair of dumbbells and lift
it up okay go really light this is not
an easy workout even one kilo you were
really fueling Donna
squeeze nice few more and good
get up all right take this moment to
breathe next workout would be unser
kalokhe a so spread your arms out put
your thumbs up and down bend your elbows
slightly and let's go small circle
forward good keep going small circle
forward keep your taping who just work
on this show that's okay lift it up do
not drop it right now
lift it up high big circles all right
reverse the circles okay big because you
have been working on your arms even this
tiny a small movement you will feel the
burn on your shoulders again if you want
to lift a couple of kilos and it will
add that intensity
all right good keep going reverse small
reverse circles speed it up and just
relax
rest it out alright next workout will be
and show the push-up with knee tap ok so
choose your options either start on your
knees or get onto your toes all right
ready
wide let's go shoot a push-up tap pick
your butt up
tap down pike pike and back down okay so
chest close to the floor
backflip pike top
and down good breathe in when you come
down breathe in without su push-up tap
tap down hand one more tap and just rest
it ah okay are you ready to challenge
your triceps do don't worry if you can't
go onto your toes okay because tricep
push-ups is not easy
give me your best effort okay so let's
get down if you need to stop on your
knees and then get into mountain
climbers all right close to your chest
as you progress onto your toes and not
inclined looks good down and up okay
pumps firmly onto the ground and climb
try not to Pike your butt too high up
okay done and up let's go for three more
done it up
this is your last workout and you would
get a one minute rest last one
boom and on fire two rounds done one
much ago my heart rate is high right now
it's telling me to take a short break
get hydrated and then we're not stopping
one more round
Oh
can you hear my breathing right now it's
high it's hard my heart rate is pumping
and that's what we want with cardio
exercises to constantly keep your heart
rate high in order to burn calories more
efficiently and drink some water
and the best part is you're not only
burning when you workout your body
continues to burn even after your
workout 15 seconds left
okay we know the first workout okay
which will be punches all right that's
good
ready adjusting my mat energy up and
let's go punch straight ahead okay left
and right
twist remember it is a total body
workout it's not just moving your upper
body okay it's moving your hips as well
with all kickboxing movements it's total
body workout okay so stay high stay look
straight ahead
look at opponent and stay focus pull it
back in I know you're tired this is a
final round your final eight minutes
give me all you got
okay and last ten seconds let's go punch
faster keep your knees soft bounce
slightly five four three two one
BAM second workout you got this man
hooks okay see I can't I can't even
remember the next marker anymore so
again in your fighting stance I'm up
hook to your left and to your right okay
look straight ahead do not look left
all right because you don't want to get
hit okay protect yourself always guard
yourself be very alert with the people
around you hook hook move your hips
twist those hips twist twist sucker
Corinne twist okay twist good keep going
small hooks lift your elbows up hook to
the side last ten seconds let's go speed
okay small hooks twist leave your elbows
up last few more two more
and rest it out alright plank walk with
rotation okay so let's get down onto the
mat start on the end of one net all
right let's go up rotate to your right
let's walk all the way to the end of the
mat rotate your left and change the
other side to rotate and keep going
twist
open up
open straight up
and twist breathe
you're almost there okay final round
rotate once more and rest it out okay
plank
up down all right right let's get
straight onto the mat give me a nice
solid low plank and push yourself up are
you ready let's go push yourself up and
down find your own rhythm okay you can
spit it up but do not compromise on your
form so tighten your core do not move
your hips too much only 45 seconds all
right let's go stay strong you are
halfway there
good keep going okay
nice solid push from the palms stay on
your toes if this is too tough then get
onto your knees
that's one more rest it up
okay all right okay I need to wipe my
sweat right let's fly it down okay see
that's wet that's your apathetic
dedication let's go fly down front race
squeeze and release squeeze and release
good
breathe and breathe breathe in okay good
that's high up as you can't squeeze for
your lat squeezing we often don't work
on our back muscles enough because we
don't see our bad muscles and so we
often be illegal at it but your back
it's so important to have a strong core
relax
all right push yourself up okay if
you're sweating like this be sure to
rate this workout five stars okay and be
sure to give this workout a thumbs up
alright spread our arms thumbs up rotate
point your elbows down small circles
forward okay and now go back right and
I'll forward again and go back good
now I want you to just reach up squeeze
it pull it back down up reach pull it
back down squeeze still working on the
lightest one squeeze okay so again pull
it up squeeze up reach squeeze up and
reach okay final round let's work on
those back muscles your shoulders and
your triceps s off squeeze pull it up
squeeze and just relax okay shoulder
push-ups with neat house okay so we just
rotate relax the shoulders and let's get
down into a high plank and let's go
push-up tap left and right good push-up
left right pack your butt as high as you
can keeping your hamstring straight
and you will feel the stretch on your
hamstrings as well so don't hike up tap
tap and down touch touch and back down
if you're struggling you can always bend
your knees slightly okay
as you progress keep your legs straight
down again tap tap give me one more
pre-shop okay let's end with a push-up
good all right okay
the last and most challenging workout
tricep push-up with mountain climbers
all right okay
so again if by this time you're
struggling I don't want you to stop
I want you to do for an easier option
okay do not stop
but you've got to finish the workout
okay
choose your option keep pushing remember
pointing elbows back squeeze your arms
close to your body legs together
struggling get onto your knees and
mountain climber all right onto your
knees down and up remember do not stop
finish the word now last ten seconds two
more reps one more oh my god so just
open up put your thumbs up stretch it
out bring your thumbs down stretch it
out
and now crossover release cross the
other side
release slowly come up okay get into
your legs stretch out stretch your
triceps and change the other five okay
then just open up and now I want to just
get down into a child's pose
just slow down your breathing bring your
heart rate down with deeply in and
slowly exhale good and now I need to
just get into a Cobra just stretch on
your upper body again with Cobra the
most common mistake is people sinking
into their shoulders all right so don't
do this push away from your shoulders
now point your toes look straight up and
I'll just go on to one side
and on the other side
twist
and now one final stretch get up sit on
your bum point your left leg forward
right leg across and just twist and look
as far back as you can
releasing the tension from your back
down to your new back remember you're
not hunched straight back
and on the other side right lick
straight left leg across twist and open
up
keep your back straight the chest open
slowly push yourself up and give
yourself a big hand they've done so well
let me know if you're sweaty like me if
your hair is messy and if your arms are
on fire let me know in the comments
below okay and give this video a thumbs
up share this video with a friends get
them to complete this workout together
with you don't forget to check out my
fitness app called a few on the App
Store or the Play Store as we will be
sharing a daily workouts to help you
towards your fitness goal there will
also be recipes and nutritional tips
work a plant as well as meal plans so do
check it out download it sign up and get
your friends to join as well and I'll
see you in my next workout
all the best